vacances ont commencé pour les parisiens
et les bordelais pour les autres ne
soyez pas impatients ça arrive
en attendant voici une idée de
destination celle du parc naturel
régional des landes et de gironde
c'est un des plus anciens de france
superficie de 170 mille hectares
reportage david bizier philippe dumas de
l'océan au coeur de la forêt landaise le
parc régional des landes de gascogne est
un immense morceau de nature
deux cent soixante deux mille hectares a
traversé le voyage débute au parc
ornithologique du teich au fond du
bassin d'arcachon où l'on observe toutes
sortes d'oiseaux une petite rivière
sziget c'est la leyre en la remontant on
arriverait au fin fond des landes de
gascogne
c'est une petite rivière qui va couler
au milieu de plateau landais qui va
drainer le plateau l'anglais qui va
couler surtout sous une voûte de
végétation on appelle ça la forêt
galerie de les gens évoquent les forêts
primaires d'amérique du sud parce que
c'est une végétation très très
exubérante pour la suite du périple
prendre le vieux train à sabres dans la
haute lande le tortillard vous mène à
l'écomusée de marquèze la ville
reconstituée d'un village landais au 19e
siècle de façon traditionnelle on va
récupérer les aiguilles de pin qui ont
séché durant durant l'hiver qu'on va
placer autour de ces fraisiers pour les
protéger bonjour oui il y en a plein qui
ne veut demande
il demande son avis tissier surtout les
enfants l'éco musée abrite des races
domestiques d'époque des béarnais ou les
derniers représentants des moutons
landais le visiteur peut observer à
loisir cette vie révolu comme la récolte
de la résine d'état
marquez bon ça me fait plaisir de faire
voir aux gens comment on travaillait
autrefois et comment vivaient autrefois
et ce métier puisque des gemmeurs il y
en a pour ainsi dire les derniers soient
ils ont mon âge car la mission du parti
double la nature mais aussi la culture
vivante
s'agit pas de conserver pour conserver
mais en concert parce que on estime que
ces espaces ces objets ces animaux aussi
ont un sens par rapport à aujourd'hui
car seuls quelques dizaines de milliers
d'habitants au vif sur toute l'étendue
du parc
l'objectif de l'institution est
aujourd'hui de développer les activités
touristiques économiques